two it's been a long time since i've
boasted
but we are number 27 in the united
states
podcast you remember that i remember and
i think you know we're having a good
year so far so you may
well be watching even better than 27
podcasts in the world maybe 26 maybe 25.
good luck ethan thank you keemstar even
keemstar supporting us at this point
welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
today's episode is sponsored by
stamps.com and eli klein
oh teddy fresh not really sponsored
but but show off what you got i mean
we've got a huge care bears collab
coming out this thursday
at 10 a.m that we've been working on for
a long time it's very special it's very
beautiful
it is very exciting let's freaking
go oh that's hot and you know what look
at our website i got it
i just i know there's nothing on it yet
but we did this really cool thing i want
to flex a little bit we have a countdown
timer
mm-hmm i mean one
day 20 hours 59 minutes four seconds
it's so cute i love it you know
the website's so boring everything's
sold out since black friday
and one day anyway we've been working a
lot on it
how are you doing today
how's everybody else doing no actually i
had the
whatever surgery and it's all fine you
had your
your uh genitals scraped hysteroscopy or
whatever it's called
wait they scrape your
you make it sound so much worse than it
is they remove
polyps and then they remove it i don't
know they scrape it
like a [ __ ] cleaning a grill i don't
know
i don't know about that come on man yeah
so we're gonna try to get
pregnant again but i had it and they put
me on there and that was my first time
and that was really cool oh eliza never
put under
she in israel had her wisdom teeth taken
out while she was yeah
people are really afraid of putting you
under it's like uh
you gotta save it for a last resort why
i don't know
you bet you wish you were put under
during the wisdom toothpaste i wish i
would be put on there for every little
thing
i wish i was under right now yeah this
is painful every process
podcast it's like the only thing i
remember is them
rolling me in into the room and they're
like okay this is the room that's the
last thing i remember
and then i woke up and it was after it's
beautiful yeah i know
it's amazing dude israel is so is a
weird place man they have like
so many conspiracy theories they're like
superstitious
i think that's what it is well where
does superstition
end and conspiracies like when i was in
israel there was
literally stickers in every elevator
saying warning do not tuck in your cell
phone
in the elevator because it increases the
chance of cancer okay
somebody will get really upset at you if
you use your phone in the elevator so
somebody slapped these in every elevator
all across
israel and convinced everybody in this
country that talking on your cell phone
in an elevator caused cancer to the
point where if you talk on your cell
phone in an elevator
people will yell at you because they
think you're endangering their health
this of course has absolutely no basis
in science
it's literally from nothing you ask them
why they go the beast
bounce around the metal the radio bounce
around the metal it's like
i don't know it kind of sounds like it
makes sense but
i mean right that's the spaces of all
conspiracy things right is that it
sounds like it makes sense but it's
actually not true it doesn't really make
sense though
if your signal was bouncing around the
metal how would it wouldn't work huh
that's a good point also radio waves
don't cause cancer like
we we live amongst radio waves
constantly
always what about standing in front of
the microwave
doesn't cause cancer what about hitting
your foot in the microwave
it doesn't cause cancer it probably
hurts though
i feel like those are also kind of like
well microwaves i don't think microwaves
cause
cancer they're not high enough energy
energy beam can only cause cancer if
it's high enough energy
to block to blast apart your dna what
the f was that
it was like computer science fiction
i thought it was a mistake yeah the only
the only [ __ ]
like a x-ray and like a you know all
this kinds of [ __ ] these are really
powerful
and they can cause cancer because they
can blast your dna
because i feel like there's a lot of
people in israel or like
um they think they're kind of like woke
so they're like um
i don't use the microwave we know
big microwave doesn't want you to know
i mean i'm almost look i don't want to
sound like an idiot like
i mean look we all have microwaves in
our house right does
microwave i remember the first time i
heard this was
one of my teachers when i was in like
middle
school and he was like he was like
trying to be like oh you guys don't know
anything he's like dude you think you
know
you stand next to a microwave you get
cancer he's like there's a lot you don't
know in the world i was like really
and i went home and asked my brother
because my brother knows everything and
he's like your
teacher's a [ __ ] idiot but your
writer is wrong sometimes
this isn't my first rodeo
trust me okay here's the answer that's
what he said
there's no evidence they pose a health
risk to people
and the us federal standards limit the
amount of radiation that can leak from a
microwave oven to a low
a level far below that would harm people
can microwave food cause cancer even
deeper down the uh
bravo the bouncing around of these heat
water molecules result in warming of
food
since microwaving does not cause changes
in food that are introduced by other
methods of cooking
it doesn't make food any likelihood to
cause cancer it literally just warms
food up by jiggling the water
okay
okay okay israelis are weird yeah and
they are very superstitious they all is
and it's true with um arabs too because
they have like the evil eye they all
believe
they're like super yeah either wearing
evil eye right now
they have this everywhere they got it on
their on their neck they got on the
wrist
you walk in the house you've got the
evil eye it's to stop the haters i mean
that's the they think that people being
jealous
cause yeah people if you like if
something's going good in your life it's
like oh careful
it's a very it's not gonna be jealous
it's very cynical because it's like
they assume that if anything good is
going on in your life
that everybody's going to be hating on
you and so it's to stop there but it's
kind of
good because it kind of just teaches you
to be modest
i think when we moved out here
um some of lena's family gave us some of
the evil eyes to hang up over our door
there's also um you shouldn't pass a
knife
to another person like you should put it
down on it
i think i did that once and someone got
mad at me because it's like you're gonna
argue you're gonna have a fight if you
give someone a knife
don't ask me for a knife get it yourself
then what the [ __ ] you want from me
also if you walk under a ladder you're
going to have bad luck
that's the same thing that's a
superstition here as well yeah
um having a mirror inside or no a broken
mirror
yeah you know
i literally i've had people yell at me
because i got on my phone in an elevator
and they're like they get into this like
this whole thing and i'm like what are
you talking about
so i assume you don't believe in
superstition
i don't really since i met ethan what
does that mean superstition are you
talking about like everything
like just you know ladder mirror
do you use that i don't i you think
walking under a ladder can give you bad
luck
well you're the guy that can't even hear
the name of the band
clarence please please please i said
clarence
please i said clarence it's just on
clearance at the outlet
wait do you believe if you walk under a
ladder you'll have bad luck for seven
years or whatever the [ __ ] they say
not seven years but how long uh if
there's a
what are the rules it's just a bad day
you know
like that day yeah it's like that yeah
or like if a black cat
crosses the road i will not drive that
way no [ __ ] way what if i turn around
at the corner of the table is that here
too
no remember if you sit at the corner
you're not gonna get married for seven
years give zach a whole new pencil as
you know
yeah that sounds like [ __ ] okay
that one sounds like [ __ ] but i'm
just saying [ __ ] they're all
[ __ ]
well spilling the salt is a thing like
that's one i live by
what about if you can't find something
take a cup and flip it upside down
say what that makes sense
so wait zach what superstitions do you
believe in because i know you are kind
of a superstitious person
well there's obviously the band there's
the ladder there's the broken mirror
um i have to get out of bed the same way
i got in
what is that a superstition or is that
indeed
that's a part of my ocd thing i think
super okay
interesting um stealing the salt
like if i spill the salt i have to throw
it over my shoulder like you have to
take a handful of salt
do you do that yeah yeah all over my
room
your mom your poor mom does your mom
clean your room zach i know you live
with your parents still
no i uh okay good you're a big
laundry cleaning my room that's good
my family thought i was cursed by my ex
once because the same week my house got
robbed my car got broken in two
my parents got a divorce and our family
dog died on the same week
what in seven days so it was your fault
your parents got divorced
i mean i don't believe in it but they
thought that's funny because if
you get cursed to cause your parents to
get a divorce come on
you just don't [ __ ] with it you just
can't [ __ ] with it i feel like i met
ethan at such a critical point in my
life because i was like 19
and i was just kind of like becoming my
own person and ethan was like
showing me the truth
eating meat and there is not gonna do
anything to you were you superstitious
about eating meat and dairy
yeah i was like i was like sometimes i
may have not followed the rules and it's
like i don't know if it's six hours or
three hours they're supposed to wait
and well you get into these rituals you
know but like yeah you just have to
think
okay there's just you grow up thinking
all of that is true so at some point
you're like wait
all of this stuff is nonsense and yes it
is
but it's like you're used to thinking
that it's a problem so it takes a minute
to be like oh
it makes sense everybody around you do
this you have to think there's like
seven
billion people in the world and the vast
majority of these people are pouring
milk and cheese all over the [ __ ]
meat
you know and none of and they're not
walking around cursed apparently they're
all out there living their life
you just have to know they're all cursed
you gotta think well maybe they are
cursed i don't know
you know what i mean i mean what does
bad luck
mean zach it means you lose money it
means you get cancer what does it mean
like what's the severity of it just
anything
that could go wrong goes wrong but
clearly that's not true by that
very fact that you're sitting before us
now by the way i don't wear this because
i
actually believe it will do anything
it's just like
the evil eye no it's just a family thing
for me like these were my grandma's
bracelets that she gave my mom
and then when i was 12 my mom gave it to
me and we
we added the hand so it's like it's more
like a
what do you call it it's an heirloom
heirloom it's a treasured possession
yeah and you may not even be here if you
didn't have that evil eye around your
breath
well zach will only know so zach
the very evidence of you sitting before
us now was kind of evidence that
this bad luck theory is not true right
well it doesn't necessarily have to mean
death
um it just means [ __ ] goes south like
just just something you want
you can't get or just the universe just
works in a weird way
don't you think it's just a
self-fulfilling prophecy that
you were looking out for bad luck and so
you find it everywhere
i think i mean it could be it very well
could be
but i mean that's just the way my mind
thinks and works
and um joker brain baby
don't stay there that triggers
everybody by the way can i show you a
funny one one day he's just gonna kill
someone it'll be like joker brandon
joker
we're like we should have believed him i
didn't take him
seriously here's a meme zach for you
from the subreddit saying this is what
they think of every time
zach says joke or brain here
you're going to pull it out here's zach
the image in my head when zach talks
about his joker brain
wait can zack see what you're showing
can you see it's that
yeah i see it yeah okay i saw that yeah
that kid's a badass
it's true he is bouncing i don't know
what they mean by that because this kid
is kind of spooky i don't think it's
funny it's like children of the corn or
something yeah
all right we do have stuff to talk about
today oh we do
we do i thought this was the
superstition hour
look i i know what it's like sometimes i
feel compelled to superstitious
thinking but i don't want to go down
that rabbit hole and so i resist it and
to the point where you just kind of
forget it sometimes i just kind of like
my mom is super like that so sometimes
when she goes
and talks about it i just kind of go on
with it because i don't want to like
what does she say to you
um like what kind of thing would she say
what that's a bad luck
oh just like uh hmm
like when we said that you like be
modest don't talk about
your success don't say what do we do
um i don't know she's it's like even if
i talk to a friend she's like okay don't
but don't show off don't don't uh like
be but you don't
i don't i know but um
she i think what she is she's so she's
guarding your success
she sees it as this delicate thing that
she just wants
she almost doesn't want to say to anyone
yeah she wants to protect this success
at all costs
that's funny so i just go along with it
i don't
i don't know don't tell anybody that
we're doing good
don't let anybody know it's just between
us
um yeah
okay we've talked about this as a [ __ ]
let me get your take on this
twitch streamer we're going to talk
about twitch streamers now okay here's
the thing about twitch
it's live ah excuse me and somebody i'm
just
thank you it's live and these people are
sometimes not the slickest people in the
world so it's prone to
all kinds of insanity going down on
twitch right
okay right uh there's a couple of really
wild incidents
i'm going to start with this one that's
lest wild somebody
donated 350 to this twitch streamer
and then he said [ __ ] i only meant to
give you 350
can you refund
the other amount and he told him to [ __ ]
off
so i'm curious what's your take on this
who's right you tell me who's right
well obviously watch the clip watch the
clock
out of here bro get the [ __ ] out of here
you want to pay for the fees give me the
fee money and i'll give your [ __ ]
[ __ ] back
w movie and w get the [ __ ] out
no dude i've been a nice guy about this
too many times
i don't care anymore how many reasons
all donations are non-refundable what's
up
you like are you trying to sue what's up
bro he's a fan yeah he's trying to
support you
no i'm sick of this [ __ ] he sounds like
uh
charlie for now this literally happened
last week which kind of makes me wonder
if he's like
sort of trying to be funny no he's
genuinely angry
i know for a fact get the [ __ ] out and
there's another clip
there's a whole thing like he was
talking about it on twitter and this and
that so
it's definitely real now here's part two
but you said 350.
do you know how many like confirmation
steps there are just like three
no dude no no no i'm in three blocks
he's literally charlie
[Music]
come on man come on come on we'll deal
with this we'll deal with this we'll do
with this
i don't care about the money i don't
need the money it just pisses me it's a
donation it's it's a
it's not it this is this no one has to
donate
you don't have to donate it's just like
why do people do this
and then i'm seeing people in the chat
spamming you're a scammer
dudes are calling me a scammer i did
nothing so wait i feel like dreaming a
bit
it's not bad oh [ __ ] thanks bro [ __ ]
10 minutes later saying oh no i didn't
mean to do that
the [ __ ] literally charlie
this is charlie the stream you know
okay so i i have a few questions yeah
they're calling him a scammer i thought
they were calling the donator scammer
because here
uh i'm not quite sure how that scam
would work though but i don't think it
would
because you have to refund it to the
same card like i could see world where
i'm assuming it's paypal right yeah it's
just paypal so you just click refund
like the same thing so there's
so they're calling the streamer scammer
which is funny so he gets super
triggered
look i mean what's what's your take on
that either well obviously
you should refund it's like it's like
customer support you know it's like
some people are going to make mistakes
like i know i
i find mistakes very confusing but
sometimes it happens and people will do
things really quickly
you know because they want to do it fast
or something and so
it doesn't matter you are on the
receiving end and i think you have to
give customer support
so yeah apparently he got this 350
donation did this whole hubbub about
like
thank you to this guy we love him and
then 10 minutes later he's like oh
[ __ ] i didn't mean to give that but
the guy's trying to support you with
three three dollars fifty cents which
you know it's not it's
it's money right yeah and now he's
telling him to go [ __ ] off
toms what do you think about this
this isn't my first rodeo
yeah yeah i mean he should donate he
should
the thing also he goes pay me the fees
you know and paypal i don't know what
he's talking about because
it's making [ __ ] up yeah i don't think
they take the fee from you if you refund
there's no fee yeah you just hit refund
it
literally takes two seconds and it
reverses the fee yeah and also even if
you just wanted to send the money back
straight to him
you can just if you're like [ __ ] it i
don't want to pay the fee you just send
the money and the fee comes out of it
so the whole pay of the fee thing is
yeah that fee doesn't make sense
he's a scammer they're right los poyos
tv and by the way i think you owe
breaking bad i think you owe patrick
gilligan or whatever his name is what's
his name
vince gilligan vince gilligan
gilligan like gilligan's isle i don't
know
uh maybe not it's vince most likely
you're wrong
gilligan based on our history look it up
well come on everybody's sitting on
their hand what's the name
it's vince gilligan oh gilligan yeah
that's correct
gilligan okay it's kind of funny names
like how you gonna walk around being
gilligan
change it it's his last name he's
walking around
and he made a great show so how about
that
he he overcame becoming being a gilligan
it's a real inspirational story would
you say be about twitch
policy i'm i'm wondering if he's
referring to you know twitch takes a cut
of every donation
thank how are they going to take a cut
of paypal donation
oh i don't know if it maybe if they did
it to twitch
but interesting no they don't take a cut
of paypal donations that's
i don't know how they would do that i
don't know yeah i mean if they're going
around
they take a cut of subs yeah they make
it out of the subs
and probably even like in platform
donation but no he's bullshitting he's
just he just doesn't want to give the
money back
because like i was thinking because like
you know on youtube if you get a
donation
they take their cut but can't you use
paypal as a source
to donate like it's not directly through
paypal but as a payment source that's
why
on twitch it's separate on twitch you
need like a plug-in right to receive
donations so it doesn't come through
their platform
where on youtube it comes through their
platform gotcha
youtube smart so they're like i'll take
some of that
wait people donate and youtube takes a
cut that can't be true yeah the super
chats
that's right they take a cut how much
they take of the super chat
like thirty percent nah well i did look
that up look it up
i wanna know what youtube's up to i
wanna know how deep their hands are in
my pocket those [ __ ] it's 30
they're taking 30 of donations that's
some [ __ ] right there
yep i thought that was a membership yeah
they take 30 memberships
dude they got their hands way too deep
in my [ __ ] pockets what
yeah that's kind of yeah i trust them i
think i don't trust them tom said like
what the [ __ ] do you know
go sell some life insurance to all
people why youtube got their hand that
deep in my pocket bro
no if people are donating to me they
expect that money to go to me not 30 to
youtube by the way that's like worth a
trillion dollars
yeah what does susan wojcinski need with
three dollars for my 10
donation call her up and ask that's a
lot
i have questions
i did a stream the other day where i got
like
yeah what about it no nothing i'm just
saying i made like 800 because i've
never
i haven't streamed it forever and then
when i went to go check they only put in
like 500 in my account
800. what the [ __ ] yeah
you ethan should get 30 of that i think
yeah where's my commission bro
gotta pay the family man
listen you gotta get your [ __ ] together
this
no you stop you stop and you listen to
me
okay garbage thirty percent
is ridiculous okay you're trying to
directly
fund my streaming operation how you can
take 30
what oh you're busy
no you know very hypocritical no don't
do that please no
i'm sorry no i won't call you again i'm
sorry all right yeah
apologies all jews and i won't call you
again all right oh thank you i love you
okay i love you talk to me she's
she she scared me
she scared the [ __ ] out of me okay guys
well we got our answer right
nice did she mention
something like deep platforming yeah
anything about it the [ __ ] i don't know
anything about
what she said but she got it she struck
fear in my heart
amy you made 800 streaming what is going
on are you gonna still work for us
i usually i yeah i don't stream all the
time like that's the
i've probably streamed twice in the past
like a month or so and yeah
i don't know who's giving you all that
money
who are these people starkiller sims
if you have sims what does that mean if
you're
like is there some transitive property
of symptom
like i mean yeah we're all i think we're
all under the h3 umbrella like you're
the simple over the leader ruler emperor
god king zach was on the stream too
right he was guest
zach do you get a cut of that i
haven't received a [ __ ] penny maybe
does that get a cut of that i mean i
feel like his
presence probably helped drive donations
no that it wasn't the one zach was on
one zag was it the one that i popped in
it was the one dan
actually oh i should get a cut yeah wait
wait wait wait wait wait what yeah
there's a hole i mean
first of all well i didn't appear on the
stream i just saw that he was live on
youtube
and then i i went on and commented in
the chat i was like what's going on in
here
to be fair to be fair he did hit when i
was on
i think it was almost two thousand
viewers and that was around 2
000
trish is right there they're promoting
starfarer
you're gonna be having your own [ __ ]
you're gonna be leaving this show soon
you don't need us
no never i did almost hit 20 000 so i
appreciate it i need that clown
so wait did you get donations when
was that that was the clout pill
yeah stop so wait zach
did you make any money when zach was on
your stream i did
so what's going on with that money how
much money you make there i mean
300 that night what the [ __ ] throw a
couple bones over to zach
yeah whoa whoa whoa dude you're making
more money from streaming what the [ __ ]
is this
then you want from payroll at this point
i need that clout how much money are you
making from streaming
i just maybe on the weekends like on
saturday nights i'll go live like here
and there but
i've made i don't let me check my
analytics i think i made thirteen
hundred
after youtube's cut where's my [ __ ]
cup yeah i feel like
is zach and i don't do a piece of the
action
sure yeah zach what do you want i don't
know i mean i'm just trying to ask
you exactly i mean i i'm not gonna i'm
just
i mean zach how do you feel about the
fact that he's rolling in all this doe
while you're there
i don't it doesn't it doesn't bog me
i'm just curious i just want to get to
the heart of what's going on here
i mean we just had a good job 20 people
for zach during that stream
yeah you what and a b played some of my
tunes so
i feel like it's a fair trade a little
fair trade you scratch my back
look at this ian you getting any ideas
i feel like you could pull on some
viewership ian came in with
the first uh yeah ab i've got an
appearance fee so we can work
well you are on the stream too you guys
can't be doing a whole show without me
what the [ __ ] is this no no no no no
you are on stream what's going on here
it's always just
me no zach dropped this is the first
time zach was ever on it but it was just
for like what not even
it wasn't a long time actually what are
you talking about we did an hour
someone posted about it on friday they
posted
they posted what me and zach were saying
you're like
you're like you want to join my stream
i'm like oh sure like i'm not really
doing anything
and then like it turned into this hour
like thing which wasn't a good time
you know i'm not denying that but um
exactly are you thinking of going
streaming now no no no
is it a b are you a clout goblin
i think you think i am but i'm a star i
might really start selling the clout
pill
i'm just asking questions i think you
can't accept my love
you don't think what do you want to do
you want to [ __ ] me how much love do i
need except
wow that's awesome no i'm happy for you
man that's crazy
all right we do have stuff to talk about
we're like getting soaked we're actually
uh
pretty much at break time 30 minutes
there's already been three months we
haven't talked about anything
all right okay let's talk about stamps
time for daddy to get paid
well you should throw it to break oh
we're gonna go do a stamps read we'll be
right back
eli you know what everybody needs
stamps.com
stamps that's right you may have thought
air water
food shelter love nah stamps
if there's one thing we learned in 2020
is that the internet is
even more awesome than we thought
there's groceries online movies online
doctors online and of course going to
the post office online with stamps.com
stamps.com allows businesses to do all
of their mailing and shipping right from
their computer
no need to leave their home or office or
home office
stamps.com has saved small businesses
all over the country
thousands of hours and tons of money
and now you can too with stamps.com
you get the service of the post office
and ups right
at your computer plus big discounts on
mailing and
shipping rates sams.com
brings the service of the us postal
service and ups right to your computer
wherever you are
it's a must-have for any business
whether your small office sending out
invoices
or an online seller shipping out orders
or even a giant warehouse sending
thousands of packages a day stamps.com
can handle
it all with ease simply use your
computer to print
you official us postage 24 7 on any
letter
any package any glass of mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready just schedule a pickup or
drop it off it's that
simple folks with stamps.com you get
five cents count it one two three four
five
cents of every first class stamp and up
to 40
off priority mail and up to 62 off ups
ship big rates
listen folks come on man
not to mention it's a fraction of the
cost of those expensive postage
meters stamps.com is a no
brainer saving you the time and
money it's no wonder over 900 000 small
businesses
already use stamps.com so make 2021 the
year you stop wasting time going to the
post office and go to stamp stock gob
it's
that there's no risk and with my promo
code h3
you get a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitment or contracts just
go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in h3
that's stamps.com promo code h3
stamps.com never go to the post office
again
so we're back we're talking about los
poyos
uh los pois hermanos exactly
uh he did he so he started tweeting
about it because you're saying is this
guy serious or what so here's his tweets
he actually erased them but and then
zach god bless him he actually got the
backup
nice so good work to zach king [ __ ]
right there bye
so he said i don't know who hates me and
why the only time i'm live
uh live stream fails reddit is
over [ __ ] can use punctuation
let me try this again i don't know who
hates me
and why the only time i'm on live stream
fails reddit
is out over out of context [ __ ] claiming
i scam my viewers it sucks because now
there's going to be a bunch of people
who don't know me
and will just believe whatever they see
by the way i already refunded the guy
so why is he again i don't understand
why he just
i mean i've used old paypal a lot you
just hit read i don't
yeah i don't understand that what's like
reverse
that same transaction you don't need to
make a new transaction you know also he
docks the guy
i think that's right he showed his full
name in the toilet i mean
it's just a name out there but it's kind
of funny
like this guy this poor guy he's just
trying to give you money
and now he's doxed and dragged and all
this [ __ ] it's like damn
had to do that to him you know what i
mean
there's a video what is this zack
the whole thing i don't know if these
people want attention oh yeah
get people spamming i don't know what it
is but this is there's no way
that people's multiple times can just
send in
a hundred dollar two dollars like so oh
no bro
i meant to donate uh two dollars bro my
bad i just added two zeros for no reason
get the [ __ ] out of yeah it definitely
happened
you're in the you're taking their money
you have to take some
give me the fee just remove the button
yeah just remove the button
you know we get orders and people i've
people will place an order and then
immediately email us that they got the
wrong address in
all the [ __ ] all the time dude like
50 of customer support is literally
trying to prevent people from making
moronic
like mistakes that you think would never
happen or like hey i got the wrong size
i got the but but it happens i mean it's
not my
place to be like hey how did you just
it's just the law of numbers when you
get it did you write a wrong address
yeah excuse me that's not your address
oh [ __ ] you i'm not helping you how can
you make that mistake it's the law of
numbers right
you say who would ever make that mistake
when you get a thousand of something
you're gonna have a
few [ __ ] ups just because you know we've
all been there you do it fast you don't
think and you go oh [ __ ] i mean i've
done that before in order you know
lose hormones too many times
i don't care anymore it literally says
i don't know what's up
like are you trying to sue what's up
mm-hmm
he's trying to sue you damn bro
no i'm sick of this [ __ ] i'm sick of
this
look i'm dead ass sick of this this
literally happened last week
cool last week there's a lot to deal
with
everyone's saying chill too
you think he feels like an idiot
whenever i have a meltdown like that i
always feel dumb immediately i'm sorry
oh bro what is wrong with me for this
why are you doing this like what's the
point of it
how the [ __ ] can you mean to send your
uh three dollars
but you sent because it's faithful you
got to put into zeros
and you know how many like confirmation
steps there are just like three
so much less no don't dude no
no i meant three bucks i didn't mean
300. it's one confirmation step
[Music]
it's your homie dude he gave you money
he's your host we'll deal with this
we'll deal with this we'll do with this
i don't care about the money i don't
we'll deal with this that's like i got
your address bro we'll deal with this
i think he meant it will refund he's
like i got your dress homie we'll deal
with you
we'll see about it we'll see who ends up
with that 350. donation it's it's a
it's not it this is this no one has to
donate
you don't have to donate you don't have
to have a button it's just like why do
people do this
and then i'm seeing people in the chat
spamming you're a scammer
they're calling me a scammer i do
nothing i mean you're not a scammer
you're just
i did give me 350 i'm like oh [ __ ]
thanks bro [ __ ] 10 minutes later say
oh no i didn't mean to do that
the [ __ ] you sound so much like charlie
i can't get over it
hey if you've been in here for a long
time you know
this has been happening for years back
in the day someone would do that bro
i would be like oh my god dude i'm so
sorry i'd freaked the [ __ ] out right
more people do it you're getting nervous
man
and i refund them not these days though
that's funny i used to do that not today
though
[Music]
there you have it let me ask you this ab
if somebody donated 350 and asked for a
refund would you do it
yes i would you would that's good to
know maybe now but
i don't know when you become a big shot
streamer oh it sounds like you're
already a big shot streamer
you can become more popular than me i
always feel bad when people donate
you don't feel that bad you collect like
20 billion dollars
i need that clout
[Laughter]
someone tried to catch us slipping on
reddit they recorded mine and zx
conversation
and they posted it to the subreddit but
we uh
we stayed loyal for the record what does
that mean what is that yeah what are you
talking about what
what's he talking about zach yeah i have
literally no idea what the [ __ ] i just
posted in the discord
uh uh uh uh uh oh what do we got here
we're up to something we got some
juice can we appreciate how loyal the
crew is like
for real papa bless these three i'm
happy okay let's see
um william a b zach and dan should start
their own podcast we will never i
appreciate the donation but we are loyal
to age three and if we ever were
i suggest that every single person
unfollows us and doesn't support us for
being
backstabbing ungrateful pieces of [ __ ]
hold on save that for later
hold on two things i wasn't there first
of all yeah you're speaking for
everybody you're looking for me
we've already been dan's already been
working on a podcast for like
actually i'm totally down for you guys
to have like a wrap-up show or something
on the
channel that's like baby's already got
one
honey no we can't do it without you guys
thank you for saying that i think that's
nice i mean again you can
you can do your own thing you guys if
you guys started all went and started
your own podcast that would be a little
odd but
i'd be like oh okay so without ethan
podcast like what would you call it
it's just the same yeah i mean it would
be odd i'm not sure yes
we asked if we could use the basement
yeah do you we're coming
you guys are like we're coming over to
work on something i'm like okay sure
fine
and then there's a podcast all of a
sudden on starkiller's channel the
without ethan podcast
we throw it in a ditch podcast i was
like what the [ __ ]
ela is even in it
h3 sign turned upside down
oh man this next story i can't even show
the video this was
really upsetting i can't show the video
i still haven't watched it because i
don't want to
can i show it to you so then they can
watch your reaction because i know i
can't show this youtube will definitely
just take a steamer on me
susan's calling wait hold on yeah
yeah no i wasn't going to sho i wasn't
going to show it
tell her about my channel no
my god okay i'm sorry no i won't even
bring it up i'm so sorry
okay mommy okay i love you i'm so sorry
okay mom all right love you bye she says
we shouldn't talk about it
right now you're a good dude
i call her mommy because that she just
likes that
she likes when i call her mommy
um i'm gonna show you the video now this
guy's not a big streamer
so it's not like he has a big audience
but
but so apparently the context is he's
playing
a football game online
madden 21 i don't know why he gets so
heated over [ __ ] madden but what do i
know i don't play
sports games i'm not and you just
watched the clip dude i saw this and i
like
i just i don't know i feel like crying i
can't show it to you guys
it's way too [ __ ] but hila you can
watch it god damn it
he's going to get this 300 [ __ ]
controller
so he's sitting in his chair with his
baby how old is that baby
listen maybe a year or less on in his
lap
right there
because he's shouting yeah can i [ __ ]
press pause
just sit right here stop i gotta go yo
i'm about to [ __ ] lose it so he threw
the bait he kind of like threw the baby
onto a bean bag
yeah frustrated
baby's crying shut the [ __ ] up
and then he screamed shut the [ __ ] up
right into the baby's face
god damn it it's like [ __ ] really
disturbing
yeah really sad honestly that's right i
didn't want to watch it i can't even
watch this look how sad i mean that's
just
it's just yeah you know it's like
it's so heartbreaking i mean the child
like you just you can't
it's self-explanatory but i can't even
say as a dad it hurts that
it really hurts more and i'm not like
trying to get this guy arrested or i
don't want him to get his child taken
from everything i just want him to get
therapy and help
because ultimately this child needs a
dad that [ __ ]
is whole and can do a good job if he he
doesn't need a dad that's going to jail
and
he doesn't need to be going into foster
care i just want this baby to get
actually some love
and not a dad who's screaming his
[ __ ] face like that for some
video game like i just want this guy
to forget some [ __ ] therapy or
something so he can actually raise this
child the way it deserves it just makes
me so sad
mm-hmm oh it's so disturbing
on stream yeah
how can you yell on your baby's face
like you can't
and he's crying because of something you
did
he's crying because of something you did
playing madden dude you're playing
madden bro
anyway he erased his channel and like
ghosted out and
he would like he just disappeared
he like renamed his twitch channel to
i'm sorry and erased everything
i don't know bro i hope i just hope
whoever this guy is
is a very strong wake-up call that you
need to
get your [ __ ] together and that that
child deserves a
dad who loves him and doesn't scream in
his [ __ ] face like that
ever it's so [ __ ] up but especially
when you have a child
it's like you really see they're just
they're so pure they're so good they're
so loving
like you're all he has it's insane
you're all
to do that he didn't choose to be here
and dude everything you put on them at
this stage in life they carry forever
you can't scream in his face like that
dude you can't
you're all he has how'd you not cherish
that
but i don't know i mean people get
[ __ ] up all the time you know
people don't they have kids on accident
they have kids when they're not ready
it's hard it's just uh
i i before we had kids i didn't care
about babies
i didn't hate him i just i was like i
don't get it yeah i know you didn't i
always
um because i did babysitting so i kind
of
felt that already but now i love babies
i love children i just because like
they're just
what did what did this baby how can you
do that i mean they're like
i can't handle it i think i left a
comment i was putting off watching it
because i
i know i can't handle this stuff i can't
even watch it oh here's a i guess people
think it's not child abuse
i guess that's definitely child abuse
like bro you don't have to hit someone
to abuse them trust me
that's equal to hitting the baby saying
shut the [ __ ] screaming shut the [ __ ] up
and your baby's face is top of your
lungs dude sorry that's abuse
somebody said that's not child abuse but
okay i guess people are debating with
child abuse or not i'm sorry bro
that is that is challenging and you know
a lot of people
so then on the other the most popular
reaction is like call
child protective services get the and so
that's not my right i do not want this
baby to go and [ __ ] foster care and
by the way the crime is not that severe
to take
a man's child away from i mean god you
all need to get a [ __ ] grip on
reality
like that is a horrible take take this
baby away
it's it's based on that clip exactly
it's hard to make any judgment based on
one clip in front of us
it depends yeah i don't know what goes
based on that clip that's not enough to
take someone's child away i mean that's
that will [ __ ] the kid up way more you
know
you want this dad to get some help and
just get a grip and realize
what he's doing how he's affecting that
child you know
some things are workable too like if you
have anger problems yeah
you can get therapy for you can you can
work of course and change
like within i don't know not that long
you can change
he's a young man right so i'm sure he's
young
he's probably strapped for cash having
because it's expensive he's under a lot
of pressure i don't know what the
relationship is with the mom
or with the parents so like he i'm sure
like my only hope is that he goes wow i
went way too far
i can never do that again right and
that's
and that's good but god
i just i hate to see it man
it hurt my heart look yeah it just was
so it just hurt my [ __ ]
my dad heart i have a dad heart now
isn't that nice that i have a dad heart
now it's really true like
ever since theater i can't watch
anything that slightly like
with kids and inappropriate
and it hurts it's like too much
well you know it's like they're just
yeah they're innocent like you said
they're pure they're
the mistake of watching that one netflix
or dateline
or what was it yeah which one is this
guy
he killed his wife and two daughters
that's just that's just like fringe
mental illness
there's no way to do it i woke up like
still depressed from it the next day it
was so depressing
yeah the act of killing a child is
probably the most heinous and he was
in such a denial at first he was at
first he was denying everything
this is the guy who just wanted to start
a new life with his girlfriend oh yeah
bro
that [ __ ] is so [ __ ] crazy so then he
said
i did kill the wife but uh it's because
she killed the daughter oh i saw that
yeah i watched that yeah and then it
turns out he killed him it turns out he
murdered the mom
in front of their kids and then took her
his
beautiful sweet little i can't even talk
i can't yeah it's too much
you can't you know be being betrayed by
your
i can't don't put me there you'll no i
know i know i shouldn't have
why'd you do that sorry we gotta have
pizza that's the only antidote
to this chaos
[Music]
blocking it right now so my thoughts
tell the thoughts to get out maybe you
get any donations
since we started no not yet
let us know keep us updated
oh my god i forgot to mention love was
in my stream too just so you know
god i am very [ __ ] up i'm the only one
loyal i'm starting to get a little bit
i'm starting to get a little insecure
now it is a h3 show without us
yeah i don't get i mean i'm getting a
little insecure thank you dan
i'm coming for teddy fresh employees
next wait dan did you
did you um or not dan ian did you say
you called in or you said you're looking
for an appearance fee
that's an appearance view i have not
made an appearance okay yeah ian would
draw on you would bring a lot of
maybe maybe he did try to stream once
but then his stream crashed
yeah well ian if you i'm just saying ian
would bring a lot i feel like he's got a
pie ticket
well there was that one time in october
during the halloween stream there was a
guest appearance by mr ian himself
oh i forgot about that that's right abe
did like h3 pizza party or something it
wasn't h3
without using my brand name he did an
ethan klein
street i was trying to do it you're
using my brand name now how many
donations you get that day in october
you just started yeah what the [ __ ]
you're already
on the cloud you're already on the cloud
bowl i was dreaming
love was in my streams before either of
us worked for you guys love was always
in my streams
abe just tweeted please join me tonight
on my live stream with special guest
keemstar
oh dude gonna be surprised at this point
i was trying to have a covered safe
halloween party
on zoom that's what it was
how many people used to watch your
stream before you joined us
not a lot give me the average
i honestly don't know come on you know i
i don't know but
plus or minus 20 plus or minus 20.
plus or minus 20. above or below 20. i
need that clock
um
i'd say probably around like 60 and now
you're at 2000 raking in that money
when i started do you think those people
are donating to you instead of me i mean
we have to be honest these are these are
our fans going over watching your stream
they're donating two thousand dollars to
you i think that's after dark money that
we would be getting
like theoretically you know like i
wonder now if they're not going to
donate to us
no i i feel bad because people donate
and i always say i'm sorry i don't
answer h3 questions but
i appreciate the donation if you feel so
bad why do you have the button
no i'm just saying like oh okay ht
related questions
yeah what they asked i know it was you
they're asking
h3 related questions yeah what kind of
questions do i ask you here i can answer
them now
what did they ask you just different
things like oh will you
show this to ethan or bring this up to
ethan will you show yeah
oh so they're giving you money to get to
me
or yeah or they'll ask questions like oh
is zach doing this is the best for us so
going on so you
so now you're the mouthpiece for the
show basically
exactly i'm an ambassador nice good gig
good side gig you've got
i appreciate the uh 10 years plus you
put into
your career that i could call you i'm
glad my brain is helping me out a lot
you didn't merge for your streams yeah
you want any more we have designers you
want us to design some merch for you
yeah yeah we'll talk
ab fresh
yeah just let us know we can do whatever
you want awesome
[Laughter]
yeah ian would pull on a lot because ian
ian is like this has this mystique where
he doesn't talk a lot but when he does
it's great so if you could get ian on
for a one-on-one you'd probably make a
lot of money
i'm sort of the rumpels still some
rumpels
when you show up when your ass shows up
magic happens
i think it's time for dan and i to start
the scooby-doo podcast
i purposely didn't bring that up dude
why the hell are you [ __ ]
airing that you guys can get paid that
scooby-doo [ __ ] is off the chain
wait what's the idea of the scooby-doo
that you guys just said do and do
do the do whoa do they do oh
i remember you told me once but i forget
let's stop secret dan you seem hesitant
come on tell me
what if somebody steals the idea ian i
don't think
i think i think there's a big market for
this yeah
we got something magical abe might take
the idea yeah yeah yeah
be more cautious of him
is the h3h3 is that copyrighted by the
way
it is copyrighted yeah it is copyrighted
but it's all good i mean you're part of
the family so
you could just make the h3 podcast the
h32
v2 podcast fine h3ab podcast
thing about starting a joker brain
podcast now that i'd watch
[Laughter]
love that zach came in wearing glasses
to my live stream and acting like he had
a joker brain
yeah it was interesting it was good
stuff
that physically pains me uh you know
it would look badass come on dude i like
that i want it
why are you zach why are you giving him
the good material where's my joker brand
we do a [ __ ] show you guys are
spending all day
trying to bolster abey's [ __ ] podcast
where's my joker brain bit
i don't understand do you guys not all
work for me
but what the [ __ ] going on here
where's my joker bit
do the joker bit for me it wasn't a
joker but i just like put sunglasses on
and
go grab them grab the glasses man
i want this show to be better hey okay
hold on let's get the joker bit
[ __ ] oh my god maybe there's any bits
you plan
exclusively for your stream that i
should know about um
i usually put my couch right here that's
about it that's my stick
on the couch i'm not very compelling
all right let's see the show is fully
let's see the joker brain zach
but telling his act messed up like he
did on my stream
what even is this
you just put your hair down and wear
some sunglasses that's it
oh man get on my left let zach do his
thing everybody says exactly how he was
talking
everybody settled down we got the joker
here
go ahead zach what do you want to know
what are you thinking about right now
oh man you don't want to know what goes
on in my head it's it's
dark stop really
it's so dark man [ __ ] what happened to
you
it's really dark because you have
sunglasses on yeah
wow yeah he was like leaning against the
wall and like
wow so good man things just like i'm
just like sitting here
all right wrap it up
beautiful you asked for this this isn't
an av stream we have standards here
anyway let's move it on oh so the
quartering had
you know our favorite the quartering
larson psycho
if reed larson's murdered it was
definitely jeremy just put another
if she shows up dead god forbid it was
jeremy
jeremy's got a gun
jeremy's you know that pearl jam song
all right
wait that's not you're mixing two songs
yeah he mixed up two songs
how does that pearl jam song go well
there's a pearl
song jeremy jeremy's spoken in class
that's what he plays in his head all the
time that's what's on the on loop in the
shed he has
me spoken anyway so he says
and get that get a load of this guy you
want a joker brain
here five hours ago yelling at your kid
is not child abuse
being 19 and hitting on a
seventh-year-old is not grooming
relying on ninja to raise your kids is
not parenting
okay nice half statements
that don't really he's making a stand
jeremy is making a stand today
i love that someone asked are you
referring to that one a stream in my
basement
that was yelling at the kid because
obviously that's what everyone's gonna
think that's the
video that's circling right now i'm
gonna respond he said no
so what are you talking about what kind
of screaming out of on a kid
yeah yelling at your well yeah exactly
yelling at your kid is not child of you
is like okay
why are you gonna make that wait you're
not referring to the video that just
was viral yeah he's being a little bit
dude god forbid he ever has kids man
his house is just gonna be covered in
piss everywhere also being painting
and hitting on a 17 year old is not
grooming well
we said it was grooming because he's
also the parents
she the girl is a fan of him it could be
although i do i do agree that ninja
shouldn't raise kids
what he said ninja shouldn't raise your
kids oh
by like them watching the videos
apparently
anyway i missed that whole conversation
by his same logic right like
we have the logic here so this is not
this this is not this
so then then so that's the podcast to it
it's fine basements are what should i
write basements or not for peeing in
basements or not toilets basically
irrefutable evidence
[Laughter]
i mean i'm just trying to continue the
saga i'm
[Laughter]
but the thing is like he did that so he
if he's gonna address me he has to own
the fact that he feeds in his basement
i just beat my basement i just peed in
my basement
i love all these channels make videos
about you for years
and then you make one response and they
go ethan's obsessed with me
oh that's a good point that's all that's
literally they all fall back on that
like
i ignore him i literally ignore his
existence
and i see one stupid tweet and i say
yeah he and then of course he
inevitably says you're obsessed with me
after tweeting twenty yeah you're right
sorry bro i talk about all kinds of
stuff oh nobody's liking my time oh
oh you're in his channel trailer even
is that true yeah unless you changed it
dude
you're obsessed with me hang up
all gas no brakes what's with that what
does
the quartering have to do with all gas
no brakes
some dumbass fan edit bro you are weird
you're a weird dude man i haven't even
seen this video
right good review
you are one weirdo [ __ ] dude man
yeah your tweet didn't uh didn't show up
anywhere the thing is
does he have you like soft blocked i
wonder how do you soft block on
i think if you have somebody okay here's
what i'm gonna do
it won't show up here's what i'm going
to do i'm going to delete this
reply i'm going to go for my main
account
i want to make sure he sees this you
know what i mean i'm going to go to the
decor drink
we should have them call in i'd be kind
of interested to have a conversation
interesting keep the field alive i love
the feuds would you let him pee
while we talk or is that too far it's
kind of gross kind of gross
dude this [ __ ] tweets like his
life why are you tweeting so much you're
so neurotic
people who tweet this much are weird i'm
trying to find this tweet and you sweet
like a hundred times okay here it is
what did i write basements or not for
basements or not
toilets yeah basements
are not i just peed in my basement he
changed his trailer two weeks ago you're
not in the morning oh
man covering your tracks hey buddy
i know what it is okay there
basements are not toilets come on okay
we got a link
we're in business folks
[Music]
when's the new starkiller channel
trailer coming out
oh yeah i'll be in that one when i get
you can do a feature
you're gonna have to pay up for that
you're rich now boy
um so speaking he says ninja should not
be raising kids
and then well what he's referring to is
ninja is called
out for not being martin luther king jr
well no he's ninja that's a hell of a
headline
first of all people wanted me to bring
attention to this apparently ninja's
just looking a little frail or something
what do you make of that photo you know
is it just a bad photo or is
it could easily just be a bad photo he's
looking very
skinny is there any other photo to look
at
because it doesn't look like a good
photo of him no but i think it's the
fact that his hair is
parted it's not all crazy like super
saiyan like usual
and he's just looking very staunch
you know it's a bad photo though so
maybe he's fine and the lighting is all
crazy like
i don't know but people are goofing on
him on all over twitter for that photo
really yeah everyone's talking about
that
everyone got bad photos it's not just
jesus
it's not just me for some reason that
photo was attached to the article
about this whole situation i don't know
they chose
that one that's just messed up
it wasn't even people dunking on it was
just that was the photo for the article
i was like what the hell
here yeah i mean that's messed up who
did who played him that dirty man
remember ninja this is him now
i mean it's good but this is like a
beautiful photoshop perfect
man here
how the how the f did my guy ninja turn
into a 15 year old substitute teacher
the rise and fall of ninja is this the
rise
man my heart my my heart goes out to
everyone who bought a troll face t-shirt
back in the day
and especially those who took a photo of
themselves in it that's brutal
thoughts and prayers thoughts and
prayers for sure
they're saying he's on cocaine i i mean
looks the same to me just a shitty photo
yeah that's nice of you why is he
wearing his hair party i know because i
feel like i get that all the time like
my mom would be like
did you lose weight you look sick in
this photo
so you saw a bad photo i don't know what
to tell you
yeah i'm inclined to to agree with you
so apparently ninja's being called out
for saying
um apparently his chat is full of
inflammatory racial comments which every
chat on twitch is
and someone asked if he is responsible
for setting them straight he says it all
comes down to parenting
you know who you want your you want to
know who your kid is listen to him when
he's playing video games when he thinks
you're not
here's another thing how does a white
kid know he has privilege if his parents
never teach him or don't talk about
racism
seems fine to me so his chat is full of
like racial stuff
i mean as much as anything else i don't
think he's like notoriously
racist but it's twitch i mean it's a
bunch of little [ __ ] in there
don't they ban those words and stuff
i do but then people have codes for it
do people go to like
extreme stream likes to be racist online
they do like these
intricate aci art of like blinchings and
i don't know i'm just i'm being they
they go to extreme lengths to be
little racist [ __ ] just for the
troll
[Music]
if they're gaming and their first
interaction with racism is one of their
friends saying the n word and they have
no idea what it is
what if it was on my stream ninja asked
is it my job to have the conversation
with the kids no because the first thing
that's going on in my head
this kid is doing this on purpose to
troll me if someone says a racial slur
on someone else's stream
it can potentially get that streamer
banned it's awful but that's the first
thing i think of yeah
can you do it's not your job i agree
somebody responded this another youtuber
daniel prata apparently who's like some
woke ass mother effort
hopefully you can see your privileged
ninja here let me pull it up
got super triggered he's one of these
what this my theory
on people like this is that he's just
trying to get laid
it's like this extra woke and he's like
kind of handsome too he exercises he
posts
pictures it's like the anthony padilla
kind of thing
favorite person on escape the night
there were a few
escape the night are you even going to
pretend to take that [ __ ] show
seriously bro
that's that youtube joey garcette or
whatever his name is show
like yeah dude you really like escape
the night no he's trying to [ __ ]
sorry mr prater get laid for watching
that show have i gone yeah
look at eerie's topless all looking
hunky
wait are you telling me you just started
filming and you're yawning perfectly you
just woke up
liar thing i'm gonna say
and then i know exactly who it is all
right here's my little breakfast
smoothie okay well here's the tweet you
haven't shown any reason to hate him
okay so you saw really okay well okay i
know who he is
so you saw what ninja said and now this
guy comes back and he says
correct but hopefully you can see your
privilege at ninja
as an influencer was the platform of 24
million and educate yourself and
subscribe on the civil rights issues in
the world
some of who look up to you and not their
parents as a role model this
is your job shut up
yeah what is he supposed to do stop the
stream anytime he read something off
color and be like
nope stop the stream we have to talk
about this comment i just saw one
comment amongst the
thousands of walls of coming stop the
stream
fortnite i don't know that ninja is not
thankful for his privilege you know
that's what i'm saying he's
trying so hard yeah do you agree with me
now
i agree on that but the rest you didn't
make a lot of sense
man i haven't thought about trump since
he got banned from twitter i have to say
the power of a twitter ban is
undeniable he is gone it's pretty scary
he is
gone from the face of the earth yeah
yeah
it's wild it's almost like
losing i don't know what's equivalent
losing a tumor getting a tumor removed
no
that's not equivalent i mean look it's
like
it's like honestly back in the day it's
almost like
like dying like it's almost like dying
it's almost like i didn't want to say it
but it kind of feels like it
if you're banned from twitter it's
almost like being banned from television
it's that
severe if you're like all across the tv
ban
you know you can't be on tv it's kind of
worse though because you could be banned
from tv but still have the direct
connection to your fans on twitter i'm
saying one it's it's great because you
could never be
worse than television so
god there's a lot of crazy stories in
the news to like okay so we've we've
talked about kellyanne
conway's daughter how she's been like
exposing her on tick tock
secretly recording her and kylian conway
if you don't know who she is
is a huge deal in politics she was a
senior advisor
to president trump um she is very famous
as well as her husband i've just to give
you a brief i mean you probably
recognize her from being on tv
she's like a trumpy maggot all the way
which is super weird considering
her husband is one of the founding
members of the leaking project
so one parent loves is a trump simp and
one
is a never trumper who he just he
literally dedicated his whole career
just bashing trump on twitter
it's crazy household i do not know how
this works but clearly it is not working
because their house is in
she quit at some point right so she
wasn't trump her all the way
until then she quitted like the very end
though yeah she but i think she stepped
down to do something else right or was
she
because she even now like she i saw her
on bill maher she was simping for trump
all the way like till the end yeah no
yeah
just even after she resigned she didn't
like renounce
him or anything like that yeah she's
she's all in you know what i mean
she ate the trump steak most people have
kool-aid to initiate
he has trump steak trump aid
anyway i love it so her six-year-old
daughter has been exposing her on tick
tock
and really [ __ ] like really [ __ ]
with her you know like here's an example
i probably can't even show this it's
like
abusive but she shows a video of her mom
like yelling at her and throwing [ __ ] at
her
and just like really horrific [ __ ] so
this culminated
and today kellyanne conway
posted a photo of her six-year-old
daughter
naked on twitter
how why how does that happen
let me say that again kellyanne conway
posted a naked photo of her 16 year old
daughter
on twitter like naked naked naked
naked
and so then her daughter made a video is
the daughter the daughter's tick-tock
here where she's like caressed my mom
and [ __ ]
this isn't this is absolutely bananas is
this it
let me see that's real and so here's
what i guess happened
the pictures were months ago and i'm
assuming that when my mom took my phone
um anytime she's taken it because she
takes it all the time she took a picture
of that so that was on her phone
um and i guess she accidentally posted
it or somebody hacked her but
nobody ever nobody would ever have any
photo like that
ever um
so kellyanne you're going to [ __ ]
jail i'm shaking
i i don't know what to do um
nobody would ever have that photo that
ever was on my phone
i don't think i've ever sent it to
anyone
um so i'm assuming that my mom took a
picture of it to use against me one day
and then somebody hacked her or
something
because there's no physical possible way
that anybody would have that photo of me
so anyway at first i was like this is
not crazy
this can't be wrong and then she makes
this and i was like oh my god
i don't know what's going on i don't
think i've ever heard of a more
so i don't know what happened but then
she's like
makes this video i think because then
all of a sudden you're like oh
[ __ ] actually my mom can go to jail for
this
so here's the second video i actually
haven't seen this hi guys i just wanted
to come on here and
address the situation uh this isn't for
us this is coming completely from me
claudia um i have faith and i know that
my mother would never put something like
that on the internet as well as
me we would never do that my mom and i
we fight like mothers and daughters but
we also love like mothers and daughters
you all fight way more than mother
daughters i know
just saying love her i will be taking a
break from social media
um because we are really tired of being
headlines
and we fight like mothers and daughters
but
being in the public eye exacerbates that
greatly
and it adds a lot of stress to both of
our lives and
i don't know what to make all this it's
crazy
it's it's wild because like i've been
kind of following her
talking about her mom on social media
yeah and somehow it always
escalates and to now it's to the point
where like
i can't even believe what's happening i
can't believe that i don't know
i mean i don't know how would you post
that on
accident so did someone
hack into her phone and post it but then
bro nothing makes sense yeah stories
make sense i don't know
but apparently when kellyanne conway
quit the white house
it was to quote focus on her family the
daughters seeking emancipation
for trauma and abuse sorry i'm laughing
it's not funny but it's just crazy
um yeah we spoke about it like kellyanne
apparently gave her daughter
covid from the president which is kind
of dope i mean in a way it's like you
got covered from the president
you got presidential covet yeah not many
can say that
i mean that's almost as good as a pardon
straight from the president from the
from the desk of the president
it was delivered on letterhead she
opened it from the pres from the desk of
the president
open it congratulations you have covered
i coughed in this envelope oh [ __ ]
thanks president
and now she says she's urging people to
stop calling the authorities
she said that she and her mother will be
taking a break from social media
george conway the parents say anything
about the photo
i wouldn't be here here's her dad and
what's he saying
oh god now the whole she said our
daughter
claudia asked me to tweet this statement
for her oh brother
yeah oh brother what a [ __ ]
man ooh families can get wild sometimes
come on man you all had a family this
wild before
my family's for a while there's nothing
on this
come on man joe biden's like come on man
come on did kelly and connie tweet
anything since that
i don't know i don't be saying [ __ ] i'd
be [ __ ]
i don't think so she usually doesn't
comment on this
kind of of the stuff from her daughter
i'm on her page right now she hasn't
yeah what was her most here let me see
when was her most recent tweet
uh the 24th sunday
those second set of videos from her
daughter were uploaded today
the ones where she's like don't call the
police anyway
uh best of the family
you know
i'm really curious what happened there
that's insane some kind of
shenanigans dude because it's all
shenanigans yeah
so ila dave chappelle okay this is a
weird one let me pull up this photo
here's a photo joe brogan posted on his
instagram
the woke elite
chappelle elon rogan
you know the ian made a really good
observation about rogan he's built like
the joker
the smush joker
let me pull that up because he's right
on man
you know the smash joker meme where do i
type for that little joker a tiny joker
you remember that meme it's a good one
they smash the joker
i thought it was a funny picture but i
wasn't familiar why on earth do i
since google update have to look 20
[ __ ] times to get an image
bruh bruh oh my god you guys got that
here he's oh my god you guys i'm gonna
lose i'm gonna freak out
here it's and then
it's a little joker got it joe broken is
built like little joke
thank you very much good job ian
leto thought it was really funny
jared leto
[Applause]
so joe rogan they had a little covid
party
they all thought that i don't the [ __ ]
these people think man
i think it was a comedy stand-up night
it wasn't
a covert party but it could have been a
coveted party because it was a coveted
party how many people are there without
him
dave chappelle got covered after
attending this place
i don't know what i i'm so tired of
people not making any sense this [ __ ] is
so it's like it's so
simple to understand just use your brain
well elon guaranteed us that kova would
be gone by like march
of last year you one yeah he tweeted out
something like
i'm gonna i'm over elon man i'm just
he's just kind of a douche to be honest
with you guys
like i like this has been a very do she
honestly
i like his cars and his [ __ ] he wants
to go to mars and all that [ __ ] but he's
just he's kind of a douche
you know it's just even if you think ron
you think ron white's going to survive
coverage even if he's
all tested it's not enough for you all
to be hanging out like that
the test could be false well that's how
true like what is so hard to understand
that's how trump had his super spreading
event because they all got tested but
then you find out the tests
and and also someone didn't actually
test that day they tested like two days
before you know it's like it's
there's all these variables it's too
many people you should not be hanging
out like that
they probably all they were probably
playing spin the bottle
they're probably drinking and schmoozing
i wonder how much alpha brain joe rogan
took that day
you think he took how much alphabet do
you think he's on right now
he looks jacked bro he's probably on
like a lot of alpha brain
anyway i just i knew this would trigger
you ela so i wanted to show you it
really triggers me
i get so triggered because
we all like especially people who have
the means to be more cautious like they
can stay at home they can be more
flexible with their jobs
you got to do your part it's just so
triggering i
we have an employee that their dad
just passed away from covin yeah super
sad
so well joe rogan's whole theory is that
it's just
fat people it's just fat people are okay
well they're still people and they're
still dying
uh excuse me fat people are not people
okay
that's my hot day no
right he's saying people should be just
taking care of themselves and getting
healthy
although our our workers dad who died
was a 82 year old who was health
who was healthy and didn't need to die
so
it's so weird i can't go over the fact
that people have this attitude that
people are just expendable
like it's just old people dying like
that's still the attitude
it's like it's just old people and fat
people dying who gives a [ __ ]
and since when do we not care about
people it's so callous
it's so heartless bro it's
so heartless
well they were old they go i mean when
they were old so i didn't have to
[ __ ] die
you can still be healthy and happy at
82. she does a lot of luck
you have good years ahead of you
yeah i'd love to see them explain it
away when it's one of their parents ah
yeah my dad yeah i gave my dad covered
and died but he was 82 so
i mean
kenneth help us now kenneth what are we
going to do
19. what are we going to do what are we
going to do to cover 19 kenneth
i see zach hey man zach what are we
going to do
man cut it out right now
so anyway what else we got uh this guy
corpse husband you know
kylie man i don't know if you know much
about him but
he's got like he's got
what's that uh k-pop band that i
bts yeah you even got like bts level of
stands
i just i opened twitter a moment ago and
he's trending
so every time i look he's trending
people love him this is something
i mean i don't know so much about him so
if you're a fan of his please don't kill
me
i don't i'm not i don't have anything
bad to say about the guy i just think
it's incredible
that people are just standing him so
hard like for example here he put out a
voice note of him just
exhaling
and people got all thirsty and like wet
over this it has like
450 000 likes
5 million
so why people are
so crazy about him he has like music and
he's got love
damn why are you laughing that's not bad
[Laughter]
he's got like the deepest voice we've
ever heard oh my god
again the thing is i think all these
little girls fantasize about what
how sexy and they but like he doesn't
ever show his face because you know he's
probably
like with peace and love he's probably
not what you think he looks like you
know what i mean the fantasy i feel like
if it was good looking it would show his
face
that's right dila but i don't know we
we might be all wrong we're not trust me
if you're handsome you show your [ __ ]
face with pride and joy
it takes guts to go out in front of the
camera looking like me
and he knows that i think i read that
he's um he's got some sort of uh
uh not disability but like um
some sort of chronic illness or
something is part of the reason that he
doesn't
show his face i just saw he was trending
he had some kind of nerve damage where
he wasn't perpetually in pain which
sounds
horrible right yeah i mean here he's
trending right now and he was saying
something about let go see
he was saying that he just what oh he
has like an all account bro can you just
have one twitter i mean with peace and
love i know you're like in pain it
should just have one [ __ ] twitter
he's got like corpse all like can anyone
find me the oh here it is
why do you have two oh a [ __ ] bro he has
fibromyalgia and gerd
oh he's got germs
gerd you can complain about gerd what is
fibromyalgia that sounds serious
do you know what that is can anyone give
me a synopsis it's a disorder
characterized by
widespread musculoskeletal pain
accompanied by pain fatigue sleeping
i'm sorry because i should have read it
before i just started blurting it out
but
go ahead yeah without laughing please
it's accompanied with fatigue sleep
memory and mood issues
oh sounds horrible he said he did a
needle
emg on my nerve conduction study and got
results that are not good i really don't
know how to process it or cope with it i
still want to participate in everything
coming up
if i see him off in anything that's why
i don't know what to do anyway
well that sucks yeah horrible horrible
yeah but
uh at any rate people love him
and i'm not here to [ __ ] on the guy by
any means i'm just
in awe of how weird his fans are and his
damn you don't like his music
oh that's hot it's not it's not my uh
to my taste no that's fine if you're new
to this and you don't know what
this is i appreciate what it is that's
fine
elo knows how to handle this sim [ __ ] i
[ __ ] up
it just it doesn't seem bad to me yeah i
agree there's a million people
to hate on you right right right right
right now
he's just making music yeah you gotta
move come on have a heart damn just
please
anyway he makes like among us videos
we have a group of crewmates on a ship
who are trying to do tasks so that we
can fix the ship winning the game
however and then he has music which
here's one cat girls are ruining my life
dedicated to dance word love i think
he's gonna claim our [ __ ] he's not that
big
is this original animation all that i've
got all of these
lyrics hold on i want to get the lyrics
i feel like we need the lyrics right
uh sure dan this one's for you this goes
out the corpse everybody loves corpse
i need to know the message behind cat
girls or ruining my life yeah
i like the title i don't want i like the
title
make a stack pepe laugh make a
got all these [ __ ] mad she sucked me
and i don't
give her bands feel like twitch staff
clip
that hey this [ __ ] finna give me
whiplash
finna was he allowed to say finna
some bob dylan lyrics right here you
know
in detroit we say finn all the time oh
you do okay yeah
this [ __ ] finna give me whiplash took
my [ __ ] breath away i'm finna take
that [ __ ] back
[ __ ] you captain and you big mad i'm
just [ __ ] trapping getting
cat girls and some big bands pull up
cause havoc jack spicy
jack spikadi how i whipped that make
more than you dad but i know you
wouldn't get that
thoughts that's hot
messed up got me look so this is the
chorus maxed up got me looking like no
face make it rain leave her wet like a
snowflake
this this is pretty epic you kind of
sound like that white girl
i tell you someone's yeah yeah i should
do this
did somebody please do like the uh
yeah the angry mom yeah reading north
node i tell her give me
i tell her give me space she's like no
way
that's a red flag [ __ ] olay
fine last nice ass cat girl she like ooh
[ __ ] around do shadow puppets back of
the subaru
i got chipped black nails and a better
[ __ ] than you so
only want me cause i'm sad [ __ ] ain't
afraid to lose you
yeah should i keep going try it in his
voice
she almost got her colorado always
[ __ ] calling me about what she said
yeah so let's listen to him do it you
can kill the music zach
but these [ __ ]
[Music]
honestly the lyrics are stupid but it's
divorced but it's so cool
yeah the voice is impressive i can't do
that
but they love him
so i'm not gonna say [ __ ] i learned my
lesson
don't go against the stands ever that's
what i've learned in my life i love it
the hard way
it's a really hard way oh well and then
just to prove how crazy his fans are
so that sound bite that he tweeted out
that got like five million views
so someone tattooed the sound wave on
their arm so
there's that hashtag only breath i mean
what
what am i oh god okay here here's my
[Applause]
turn
what's the idea also he's like snapping
he's just emo as [ __ ] bro he's just
there's a lot in the side
he even responded he said oh my god
i'd be like dude you need to get that
removed i wouldn't endorse that like
i'll be like
well someone already got did that too
yeah you get it removed
i'll pay you to get it removed you don't
want to make them feel bad
well what can you do you can't go i mean
it's like you if that's your fan you
want them to be well adjusted to life
you can't just go out there
walking with the sound bite of someone
breathing it's like
you gotta get ethan's sound wave now
that's the only way to go
yeah that you're not going against the
family at this point all right
okay save this ready
i'm just trying to make an interesting
sound wave for you that sounds like
gilbert grape's mom
oh god
oh my god forget that
copd or something
i'm saying he got a sexy breath come to
me sounds
like you're got a problem
[Laughter]
is looking like radio picked up we get
when we get to 50 000 members i'll do it
you know i want to get a tattoo so
[ __ ] bad and i'll
that that actually sounds like a good
story on it too
i'll end all authentic authenticize it
that's what they say
authenticate it you'll sign up yeah i
could call the sim but zach is the one
who's always down
zach is the one i feel like that's not a
simple he's a golden boy
he's a golden thank you damn damn that's
a nice way of saying it i guess
yeah there's a difference it's a big
difference
big difference all right well
thank you everybody for watching
we'll be back on friday the live show
we'll be going
live on friday as we usually do thank
you so much god bless everyone
tomorrow is wednesday i have nothing
that does not
involve me i will not be here or working
wednesday is my day off from the podcast
we're working on teddy fresh on
wednesday right deal
right right
you know what a b will be doing but
that's not the question
now can you stream on days when there's
no podcast
no i don't only on the weekends only you
only live stream on instagram
if you call it yeah i guess well it is
live
[Laughter]
i mean but like i'm like target and
stuff what
why would you stream when you're at
target because lena takes forever and i
get bored
until you want to enter people i know it
was you fredo
helps pass the time
bro i'm gonna take your ass out on a
lake
like like fredo corleone yeah
you never go against your family baby oh
[ __ ]
find me out baby oh no i'm back
what have you done you've given i've
given you this opportunity of giving you
this stuff
and i find out that you you're streaming
on instagram live when you're at target
wondered i don't
deserve this disrespect what have i done
to deserve this destructor to stream
you're using the h3 brand to build an
empire where
where is mine
where is hiding where's my cuts of tithe
you don't even tithe
and now you come to me you're asking me
to promote your
bootleg show
and i cannot do this for this thing you
ask me i cannot do this
nah you break my heart friend
careful you can't call people foreign
[Music]
kill the [ __ ] music or this will
never end
all right that's about it eh
okay well thanks for watching all right
i gotta i just gotta walk
was this watchable should we cut the end
i could take over i'm just kidding yeah
of course of course
just kidding no
no no hopefully this was a good episode
of something
this is my show enough i'm actually
starting my own podcast that's right
um with all of us
early mornings it's gonna be cold
nice um okay i want to smell feet